- So welcome to the show.
- Thanks for having me,
thanks for having me.
- I'm so excited to have you on here.
I I, The reason why I made the
"I Know What You Did Last
Summer" joke, its 25 years.
- I know.
- 25 years yesterday is the anniversary.
- Yeah, crazy, really crazy.
- Well, you've got a couple new films
out, 'cause one wasn't
enough I guess, for you.
So Summit Fever.
So where did you, where'd y'all film that?
- Summit Fever was an amazing experience.
So it's a, it's a mountain climbing movie
and we shot it in Chamonix France,
on top of Mont Blanc
which is one of the largest
mountains in the world.
The fact that we were shooting
it during Covid was amazing
because we had that mountain to ourselves,
which is like,
you would never have a scenario
like that again, you know?
And so there were times
where we're looking around.
We had a very small crew
because when you're
doing this type of film,
you only bring essential elements
up at that kind of altitude.
It really took me back
to the reasons why I be
wanted to become an actor,
to have those rare
experiences like that, yeah.
- It is cool what y'all get to do,
or like study for, like
if you're playing a role,
it's a really, it's a really cool job
because you get to learn a
little bit about everything.
- Yeah. Well, specific to "Summit Fever",
one of the reasons I took the job is
because I always wanted to
learn mountain climbing.
It terrified me, but like,
it was something that,
a skill that I wanted to have a sense of.
And man, I'll tell you,
the first climb that I had,
like, I literally started shaking,
like, I have to focus.
I mean, that's all legit.
The icicles on my,
That's not makeup you
guys, that's, that's,
that's really what we were going through.
So when you do a mountain climbing movie
on an independent budget,
there's no green screen.
There's no special effects.
So all the stuff we're doing
in that movie is legitimate,
and the ice climbs were terrifying.
Absolutely terrifying.
- Yeah. Nothing
about anything you just
said sounds exciting to me.
It sounds exciting to watch,
you do.
- Yeah. Yeah.
It's not for everybody, obviously,
and I'm a bit of an adrenaline
junkie, thrill seeker
so, I loved it.
And it's something that
I will continue to do.
I, I really dug it.
- That's really cool.
We get one life mine as well.
- Yeah.
- I mean I won't be
doing it, but you do it.
For all of of us.
- You can watch, you can watch.
I'll send you pictures.
- You can show me what we're capable of.
- Yeah.
- So your other film is a thriller,
and it's called "American Murderer".
So other than it being
about an American murderer,
like, what's it about? (laughs)
- Well...
- I was gonna say what's it about
but I guess an American murderer. (laughs)
- You're smart.
- I am so clever.
- Not just a singer. (laughs)
- It's a, (laughs)
"American Murderer" is
based on a true story,
about a guy named Jason Derek Brown,
who was on the FBI 10 Most Wanted list
at the same time that Osama Bin Laden,
Whitey Bulger were on it.
Except for Jason Derek Brown
looked like a blonde
haired, blue eyed surfer
from California, which is what he was.
He killed an armored car driver outside
of a movie theater in 2004,
and he's still at large.
So, part of what we're hoping
with this movie and people seeing it
and starting the conversation,
is, we, we might actually
catch this dude, finally.
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah, yeah, he's still out there.
(audience applauding)
- It trips me out like,
when y'all come out here
and we see stuff and then
all of a sudden it's,
like, based on real events.
That scares the crap out of
people, just so you know,
like, I'm like, wait,
I thought we were just being
entertained by a story.
This guy's out here? I'm
like, that scares me.
- But then doesn't it also,
you know, invite you to
lean in a little more
and kind of learn more about the story
after you've watched the movie
and to verify the realities of it?
I heard you talking to Jessica about that.
- Yeah, I go down the Google, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
And I think that's interesting.
Like, I love true crime stuff.
I love to research
interesting stories,
and so I think that's
part of the fun of it.
If you can call it fun,
I guess, I don't know.
- No, people do.
My, all my friends love, like, true crime
and I'm like, the only one that's like,
I'm good.
- (laughs)
- But I, I think it's really cool though,
that you tell that story though,
'cause that would be incredible that,
for whoever's lives were lost in that,
that armored thing, like, that's amazing.
What if they did, they did catch him?
That's cool.
- I think there's a real chance
because there hasn't been
much talk about this guy.
There's theories about where he might be.
Would be in Australia or Mexico,
but I'd like to see him brought to justice
because I play the man in the movie
who was trying to do that back then.
And I would like to see him satisfied.
- Yeah. Oh my gosh.